hey das ist human day to me in der
Reportage zum Thema Hype und
abnehmspritzen danke viel mal dass er so
fleißig mit kommentiert könnt danke für
eure Frage und für euch Kritik auf die
Gang jetzt den gradi und am Schluss
können wir Jenny wo der Reportage über
Kommentar wo sehr oft hier sind nämlich
das Personen wo das Medikament wasamping
zum abnehmen würde der Diabetikerinnen
Medikament wegnehmen
Trend findet vor allem weil ich als
Diabetiker auf das Medikament angewiesen
bin aufgrund dieses Trends ist das
Medikament deshalb nicht vorhanden in
der Apotheke toll für welche es wirklich
brauchen danke vielmals mitkommentiere
und danke an dich weiter dass du Dinge
erfahren
ganz wichtig und das möchte ich nochmals
betonen es handelt sich da um es
verschreibungspflichtigst Medikament und
dass man das als Person wo Gott abnehme
für uns hängt von medizinischem
Fachpersonal ab und vor ganz vielen
verschiedenen Kriterien
es stimmt dass es in der Vergangenheit
tatsächlich ein bestes geht auch will
der Run für Personen
Medikament und ich finde da kann und
muss man unbedingt kritisch durch
Gesundheit zu erkrankte Menschen von
Wirkstoff wie der Medikament abhängt und
trotzdem wünsche ich dass mir sehr
gegenüber allen Parteien gibt
dann schreibt Uli das sind leider gar
nicht gefallen hat Reck ist ja schon das
öfter sondern ein grenzwertiges Format
aber diese Reportage war ja wieder mal
ein Tiefpunkt der Fokus scheint vor
allem darauf gelegen zu haben richtig zu
Gendern und die Porträtierten möglichst
nicht zu erkennen obwohl der Nutzung von
der selfie also schon gefragt
subjektive Sicht wie das Thema da das
heißt aber natürlich nicht dass man weg
dem Thema nicht gründlichem
Protagonistinnen
und dann noch zum gendere mir ist es
wichtig zu Mini Reportage alle Menschen
aussprechen und inkludieren und darum
tue ich mit dem Doppelpunkt
aber das heißt überhaupt nicht dass wir
euch wenn der Ideologie Rufzeichen
dann hat der Japan er fragt zu der
Spritze und zwar schrieb die Person ich
hätte das Bank gefunden
ist
Medikament ist der Wirkstoff
Therapie von Diabetes verwandelt und Dir
wo sich das sprüht wenn sich das einmal
in der Woche geht
wirklich von meiner Hormon nachher wurde
schon im Körper hängt und zwar macht das
das Buch Speicheldrüsen nach dem Gasse
Hand tut insulinfrei setzen und so wird
mit Zucker aus dem Blut die Zahlen auf
Klo und gleichzeitig haben der Wirkstoff
der Appetit und macht sich der Marke
langsamer entleert und seitdem tut man
eben auch weniger essen und nimmt Zungen
liegen Masse auf falls ihr euch noch
weiter zum Wirkstoffen informieren dann
lege ich euch der Artikel von SRF Wissen
auf Herzen mir verlinken euch ohne jede
Video beschrieben und somit können wir
gerade zum nächsten Kommentar über wo
eben aufzeigt dass Medikament wirklich
nicht zu unterschätzen ist schreibt ich
habe die Spritze vom Arzt und ich habe
gar nicht vertreibt mir 24 Stunden lang
schlecht sind
danke für die Kommentar ja sind wirklich
nicht ganz einfach
Durchfall und Verstopfungen aber es
andere Sachen
Reaktion wo man sich Spritze setzt also
im Bein oder im Buch oder auch zu
Gallenstein oder Erschöpfungssyndrom und
auch Schwindel oder
geschmackvoll gesehen
und jetzt macht sie es anders sie nimmt
ab indem sie jetzt Kalorien Defizit
hervorruft dass sie denn sie weniger ist
und für Achtsamkeit im Alltag gemacht
und sie ist sich auch in der Trikots
klar wurde also deine Sache wo sie zum
Essen braucht haben
es freut mich sehr dass du ein Weg
gefunden hast für dich funktioniert das
ist viel wert und wir zu erwähnst ist es
auch mega wichtig zum sich seine Tracker
klar werden also aber wann ist man
vielleicht das wäre eine Gefühlslage ist
mehr und tut mir auch unbewusst erstens
und darum ist es auch so wichtig dass
man nach dem medikamentöse behandelt
auch andere Therapien im Anspruch nimmt
also das mit zum Beispiel es
Bewegungsprogramm hat oder dass man
psychologische Hilfen Ausbruch nimmt
oder drinnen
energieschwangerschaft macht und darum
bist auch der Hersteller die das muss
Medikament werden Schwangerschaft nicht
auf ihn schwanger werden mindestens zwei
Männer wieder absetzen
dass man doch besser sind
Ernährungsumstellung
ja klar lebe deine Spritze als eine
Ernährungs Lebensumstellung in Angriff
zu nehmen ist halt schon bequem was oft
genau das Problem ist
wo mega viel verschiedene
Probleme hat oder wenn man ziemlich
viele Stoffwechselerkrankung hat das
dicke Menschen
übrigens das hartnäcks Vorurteil wo sich
leider immer wieder Gesellschaft halten
er repräsentative Studie aus Deutschland
zeigt dass er uns zwei Drittel von der
Befragten dass ich mir wichtig die
Menschen einfach zu wenig bewegt und uns
viel würde das sein und kann man 28 %
nur andere Gründe
Stoffwechselkrankheiten
ich finde es wichtig zum Adipositas
differenziertes
urteilsfälle wenn euch die Studie
interessiert ich finde sie ohne Video
video
Beschreibung
finde den Trend auch bedenklich
was soll das mit dem Mehrgewicht und
hochgewicht der korrekten medizinischen
Begriff ist einfach übrig oder
Adipositas einfach anerkannte Begriffe
verwendet danke vielmals für den
Kommentar ich sage der Reportage
wirklich richtig und dick will das
Selbstbezeichnung ist für dicke Menschen
wo also weniger diskriminierenden
Umgang mit diskriminierten Gruppe immer
wieder dazu jetzt lernen
Andreas fragt sich die Frage sollte
mittlerweile eigentlich ihr lauten
welche tiktok Trend ist heutzutage
ungefährlich und wir können dann gefragt
Avant für ihn ein Trends
wenn die eigene Gesundheit und würde der
eigenen und anderen Menschen gefährdet
ist das finde ich sehr entspannende
Gedanken vielen Dank für das ich finde
es gibt natürlich auch Inhalt wo harmlos
sind wo der Unterhaltung
zum Beispiel auch informativer Zwecken
also ich finde es mega cool dass es zum
Beispiel privat und der Fachpersonen
geht wo ihre Erfahrungen mit mental
health teilet und zufällig der Meganie
Stellen betroffen und zu
einstigmatisierung
auf Social Media kursiert und Leute zum
Teil auch probiere die illegal Draco für
mich mega viel verschiedene Sachen
zusammen zum eine Medikamente Missbrauch
aber auch der Druck von der Gesellschaft
auf dicke Menschen und auch
unrealistische Schönheit sieht ja
spannend gefunden
das Problem mit Gewicht sondern
Gesellschaft hey danke vielmal für die
Kommentar du sprichst und wichtige Punkt
der Druck muss
zwei Drittel von dem Mann reden von mir
wichtig sind abnehmen und bei der Frau
sind sogar noch nämlich rund 34 und wie
der Druck kann uns
gesehen also ständige Kommentaren
kritische Blick auf die Straße und dann
auch abfällige Aussage reduzieren
und dann habe ich einfach nur Jenny
gefragt wie sie auf Kommentar lockt und
ob sie die Aussage täte zum Teil auch
verletzen und sie hat mir das doch ganz
gut hallo liebe Anna ja und deine vom
auf deine Fragen einzugehen ich habe
jetzt nicht so viele gelesen aber die wo
ich gelesen habe da habe ich jetzt zum
Beispiel was gesehen dass ich da zum
Beispiel für uns zum Spiri
da Süßigkeiten aufgetischt habe also
und das wird dann gerade kritisiert ich
finde das schon ein bisschen krass dass
die Leute sowas die so für eine Meinung
dazu haben finde ich echt
interessant und krass also das wird
einem eben es wird einem schon
vorgehalten wenn man mal also ich esse
das ja nicht jeden Tag zum Siri also du
warst mein Besuch und da setze ich dir
natürlich was Leckeres auf und ich es
dann natürlich mit und das ist aber
sofort wieder kritisiert wird so ja was
frische Studenten da auch die ganze Zeit
das zeigt halt natürlich auch mal wieder
dieses Bild wo die Leute haben da ist
man undiszipliniert man ist einfach zu
viel und das sind halt alles einfach ich
mein klar jeder hat seine Meinung ich
finde das völlig okay da kann das
kritisch sehen jeder kann sagen ich
würde das nicht machen das ist jedem
selber überlassen aber verletzen tut
mich das auf gar keinen Fall ich sehe
das ganz ähnlich wie Jamie weil die
beiden Szene bitte Jenny und bitte Elena
sieht das Tier die Szene sie und einem
Nachmittag zu mir reichen
so und dann ist Angesicht gefallen und
zwar das tschechische sitze auf tiktok
kein Videos mehr zu der Medikament
postet und ihre sieht fragt wieso dass
das so ist weil ich glaube es ist alles
gesagt über das Thema
mein Gewicht ist jetzt auch wirklich
lange Zeit schon im Stillstand das geht
sehr langsam runter also mir fällt jetzt
auch nicht mehr wirklich viel ein was
euch dazu noch sagen könnte die
Reaktion auf die Videos sind eigentlich
auch immer
ähnliches werden immer dieselben Fragen
gestellt wo ich halt denke ja ich habe
eigentlich alle Fragen in den ganzen
Videos schon beantwortet und das ist
jetzt gut für mich und ja ich hoffe Dein
Beitrag konnte die Leute ein bisschen
aufklären und dass man sich da selber
eine Meinung drüber bilden kann
und eben jedem ist frei überlassen wie
er dazu denkt und was er dazu für eine
Meinung hat
vielen Dank fürs zuschauen
würde